rather than Trump firing up another big
crowd today this time at the annual NRA
convention in Dallas we are all finally
putting America first we are seeing the
incredible result as a result of our
massive tax cuts and everybody is
benefiting and everybody is happy and
the Democrats are very concerned you
watch how well we do in 18 you watch
don't be complacent Kanye West must have
some power because you probably saw I
double my African American poll numbers
we went from 11 to 22 in one week Thank
You Kanye thank you he just saw the
recent haul it came out the rest this is
51 or 52 it's the highest level
Democratic lawmakers have voted against
legislation to close deadly immigration
loopholes like catch and release how
about that one we caught up
Oh release him bye-bye we're going to
keep the violent criminals out Senate
Democrats like John testin so what
happened there what he did to one of the
finest people in our country what he did
to the advil what he did is a disgrace
he went on to expand on the subject of
gun rights in a speech before thousands
of Second Amendment supporters and thank
them for their patriotism watch this the
true american tities
of the NRA who defend our rights our
liberty and our great American flag you
have never stopped fighting for our
beloved Constitution they said you know
going to the NRA convention and speaking
today that will be very controversial it
might not be popular you know what I
said all right we'll take it around the
table Gregg he was having some fun today
yeah I always used the metaphor
he's like a classic rock band who does
hits in front of a loving crowd you know
like the the wall is his stairway to
heaven but he introduced some new hits
the Kanye is a new song and the best
part without question is the John Kerry
material that he introduced which was
stellar comedy roast when he talked
about Yale when you're 73 he shouldn't
be riding a bike and about how he felt
the way it was this perfect stuff and I
was finding I mean this to him is
entertainment for himself an
entertainment for others and it's at
what I guess it's an antidote to the
news because when you're listening to
the news all you're getting is the bad
news you're getting the stormy stuff and
the collusion accusations but when you
when he gets up there what he does is he
talks about the job numbers he talks
about North Korea he talks about the
good news which is the antidote to the
bad news so it's kind of healthy for him
and it's healthy for his supporters and
it's actually healthy for people
watching at home to see the other side
well if you're watching Fox I don't know
if the other networks took it live but
we did and so it's in some ways I'm the
bully pulpit really is very powerful if
you're going to give a speech in front
of a big crowd and you'll get a chance
to watch it it means a lot more than
watching any sort of newscasts
yeah absolute is perfectly produced and
I think a good plug for your book and
the good news is right so he's leading
with what the good news is he's changing
the dialogue and the narrative because
the media won't give it to him so he's
gonna take it and take charge so he's
very good when he's at these campaign
rallies speeches or in front of a group
that's a receptive audience that kind of
you know they're picking up what he's
dropping so it's perfect he really feels
at home in a situation like that as well
I I actually
watched in a room that had MSNBC and CNN
on it and there were a couple of
interesting things first of all it's the
president's only time with unfettered
access to actually communicate his
message but I was fascinated because
there were cutaways there were times
when the audience was applauding and the
audience would you know Donald Trump had
stopped speaking for 15-20 seconds
because there's so much applause Fox
News went to cutaways of the audience to
show what was actually happening in the
room CNN and MSNBC no cutaways there's
no way they were going to show that
audience but let's remember going into
2018 it's about getting the base
enthused and that's the problem he spent
a whole section of his speech talking
about the enthusiasm level and you
better if you like your sex you better
you better get a good point about the
midterms on going into them that that's
never necessarily easy for a president
in their first midterm they usually lose
seats and even though he's approval with
Republicans is high probably highest
that it's been maybe like I think it's
88% 90% that doesn't always translate
into enthusiasm and getting out to vote
and do you think that was part of his
ploy today was clear if you watch the
speech that's clearly what he was saying
don't be complacent we just played that
clip Dana but so what was interesting to
me is if you consider the midterms you
look at the poll numbers poll numbers
have turned in favor of gun control very
strongly and after Park Lane remember
the president was in the White House I
think we carried it here on Fox having a
meeting and saying you know what I think
we need stronger gun control you guys he
says to the others in the you guys are
afraid of the NRA I'm not afraid of the
NRA and of course then about five days
later he flip-flops but nonetheless he
is trying to make the case that he is
the man who the NRA poured 30 million
dollars into and during his campaign and
that he is still the NRA Sprint I think
we after he got elected he said you know
you were with me and I will always be
with you were you surprised by we didn't
talk a little bit more about that like
what he did he said he was willing to go
to challenge the NRA but I think one of
the things that the president does is he
says well that makes sense and then a
couple days I was like oh wait now I
understand why it for example arming
schoolteachers might not be something
you can do nationally that that will
have to be decided on a case-by-case
basis on
in the district I think that the the
blessing and the challenge of Donald
Trump II sees like the first
conversational president we've ever had
so we'll just talk about anything and if
something if a happens he'll talk about
a and he goes you know what that upsets
me what just happened and then it be
happened so go well wait a second I mean
he may he went on a long tear on how if
one person has a gun lives would be
saved in areas where there were no guns
and it's you know there's a CDC Study
Center for Disease Control study that
was not published that supports the
claims of two million-plus defensive gun
uses and this isn't this is an important
thing I think fellow to talk about so he
did it but I always get the sense that
the speech is essentially the same and
then he tweaks it depending on the law
it's for the NRA so he drops like ten
minutes of that in the NRA but that was
I think there was a stock positive
speech about deeds overall it was about
deeds in the face of what you get from
the media which are words what you know
I think the whole gun movement the NRA
right now is on the defense of gun sales
down Smith and Weston are the ones who I
think are saying you know what you know
they also outdoor brands there's the
outdoor brands make Smith and Weston's
their stocks are down Remington's in
bankruptcy I think there a lot there's a
sense that you have a Republican in
office so it's not driving the the gun
buyers to the gun stores which is what a
you know they said Obama's gonna take
your gun well now nobody think you
should be happy then because that meant
we've saturated the market everything
guns but what strikes me is that so many
people including teachers who are
clearly opposed to carrying guns into
school are including suburban Heights
are saying you know in the app in the
aftermath of parkland maybe something
should change and then that brought up
what I think was the controversial issue
regarding the President's speech today
and also a vice president Pence which is
the Secret Service said no guns in here
and so you get people even NRA
supporters who are attending the
convention saying wait a minute they
don't trust the good guys with the guns
how can that be well you can see why if
so many Americans would say of course
not you shouldn't have a gun around the
president you shouldn't have guns around
here people in the room with guns
about one other thing the president
discussed and it's Greg's favorite part
he mentioned it in the opening remarks
about North Korea take a listen to this
the last administration had a policy of
silence don't you make don't talk if a
horrible statement is made about the
United States don't say anything oh my
god and we have the former
administration not the best negotiator
we've ever seen he never walked away
from the table it's just to be in that
bicycle race where he fell and broke his
leg at 73 years old you never go into a
bicycle race so say Justin we're saying
this is going to be nuclear war
we won't happen you know what gets you
simply a weakness one of his strengths
Jason I think is that he uses humor to
then make a point his point being that
you being strong against your enemies
yeah we'll bring them to the table and
that's that that's actually he's just
strength do you remember when Barack
Obama he what he said he was big into
skeet shooting and they had pictures of
him out there you know pretending to
shoot skeet and then he had John Kerry
supposedly out deal pheasant hunting
nobody ever bought into that but Donald
Trump he has this authenticity that
connects people even though he doesn't
pretend to go and do that right yeah
fake it yeah yeah this was great I think
for him he felt like he gets back into
his element to his groove he right away
you know this is something coming in the
aftermath of the Parkland shootings he
was able to go in front of the NRA which
is taking a lot of criticism lately
there's a lot of people trying to
abolish the Second Amendment get after
your guns he went straight to them to
the crowd because he then invited people
to the White
house to have this discussion too and I
thought that was important to show that
he's listening to both sides people who
were concerned about gun safety gun
violence and then going right to the
group that's trying to protect the
Second Amendment so I like it's right up
you know in in your face and not afraid
to answer questions and talk and get to
the issues so I think he's got to do
something with Republicans because I
mean you look at what happened in
Florida and you know you're looking at
other states some with Republicans
Kasich in Ohio but you look at Vermont
you look at Oregon more and more
Republicans are saying yeah we buy into
the fact that most Americans now
overwhelmingly want some reasoned gun
control it's not about taking anybody's
guns away I don't think anybody's
talking about well a lot of people are
talking about I don't think this is
excessive there's long just need to be
well there you go no I said I stinked
former Supreme Court justice Stevens
said something like that in the op-ed
but it's not the kids it's not the
parking kids and it's not most Americans
what you're seeing in terms of the
60-plus percent who want more gun
control is better background checks
maybe in Nancy Pelosi in charge and
that's exactly what has happened they
will do everything they can to take away
guns don't you think though Jason that
would work against that just politically
for thinking Nancy Pelosi you might want
to do that but as soon as you're done
with the midterm election we're talking
about the general election correct and
if Nancy Pelosi were to do that how you
want to make sure that Republicans
really turnout in 2020 Nancy Pelosi
should try to pass a gun control that
means it and that's part of the reason
there's frustration that Congress never
gets anything done can I just return to
that video that we played of him talking
about John Kerry if you noticed he did
the panicky man impersonation which is
when he moves his hands like this it's a
lesson for all of us that it's not a
it's it's not specific to any particular
person he does that but that's not the
same thing as you look back same thing
pretty much pretty close okay